well good evening from St Michael's on
wire in Lancashire police are expected
to give an update within the hour
following the discovery of a body in the
search for the missing mother of two
Nicola bully a body was discovered
yesterday about a mile from here the
place where she was last seen walking
her dog after she dropped her two
daughters off at school on the 27th of
January well our correspondent Katarina
vitotsi is here with me and Katarina I
guess first of all we've got to think of
the family Nicola Bully's family tonight
and and what they must have probably
already been told
I think for many of the people that have
been here over the past three weeks
media colleagues I mean by that have
been struck just by just how Frank and
open and honest Nicola Bully's family
have been throughout this whole search
for her and they have spoken about her
about the sort of person she was and
about how desperate they were for her to
be able to come home and give her two
daughters Harriet and Sophia who were
nine and six a hug we've spoken with her
parents and her sister and her friends
and her family and I think they've tried
to convey as much as possible a sense of
who she was in the hope that there might
just be a glimmer of hope a bit of
information shared with police by
someone seeing all of that that could
have led to her being brought safely
home and now as you say ahead of that
news conference your thoughts just
absolutely go out to them her partner
Nicola Bully's partner Paul Ansel
describing it to us yesterday is utter
Agony no words I mean what can you say
after three weeks of just desperately
hoping for her to come home and that
news yesterday that they would have been
told by police who were obviously
confident enough to share it with them
um yeah no words I mean Paul Ansel sort
of describing it even then there are no
words for how they will be feeling now
after what has been a search of such
unprecedented scale by Lancashire police
and enormous public interest focused on
this small Lancashire Village and
focused on this family who had just been
so desperate for any news that would
bring Nicola home and those questions of
course you say that unprecedented in the
scale of a search and it's a small area
although it's a long river and the
questions about the fact that she was
found or that this body was found within
a mile of of where Nicola was was last
seen yes exactly right I mean in that
press conference on Wednesday last week
Lancashire police detailed how large and
unprecedented the scale of the search
has been 300 homes I think it was and
outbuildings and Caravans that they had
searched thousands of lines of inquiry
um that they had followed up with
stretching 15 they're such stretch 15
miles of this River all the way from the
bench where her phone was found a little
bit Upstream of that then Downstream all
the way to the coast and also the coast
off Morgan Bay and as you say for her
then or for a body to be recovered just
a mild Downstream is quite extraordinary
we know that it's not just been police
teams that have been searching there
have been independent search and rescue
experts who volunteered to come up and
the family asked for them to be part and
involved in the police search and
Lancashire police accepted all that help
those teams were not able to find
anything in in the river at that time
and we understand that it was passes by
who yesterday were walking along that
stretch who found this body and alerted
it to policing in the Reeds surrounding
the sides of the riverbank but as you
say in a search that's been so enormous
for this body to be recovered but to
mile Downstream you know we know this is
a tidal River by now it's been something
that we've been speaking about a lot
bodies and by that I mean anything
within the water can move backwards and
forwards and change location
um but as we also know this is a very
deep River one search specialist said it
is very murky it is a difficult search
and things a stretch of river that might
be searched one day searched again the
next day there might be different things
to find and now everyone just waiting
for this formal identification to take
place and as you say this is a small
community they will be waiting now along
with everyone that's expressed an
interest in this case to find out
exactly what's happened well you
mentioned the huge police search the
private team the members of the public
have been helpful early on in the search
but there's been there have been people
who've not been helpful according to the
police and certainly to the to the
family and that's another feature of
this case those those amateurs who've
got involved and a lot on social media
as well that hasn't really helped with
this serve yeah I mean I think I'd be
right in saying it's one of the first
times I've heard a police press
conference it's expressly called out
what they called tick-tocking private
detectives it's certainly not a feature
in many investigations we've heard so
about before and in fact we've done some
analysis today on the Sky News data and
forensics team that's shown just in
terms of engagements or social media
across tick tock on Twitter they've been
1.8 million engagements on stories
featuring the hashtag Nicola bully there
is such an enormous public interest and
as part of that it's drawn as you say
amateur sluice perhaps that's even two
grandiosea titled to give them they're
people who've wanted to come please say
that they've been unhelpful they've
added Fuel and speculation to to a story
that's already got enormous public
interest and we've seen outbuildings
that have been smashed into police say
properties private properties have been
broken into by people who've been taking
photographs and videos and adding that
speculation onto their own social media
channels there's even been
site set up for Nicola bully
investigations and amateurs loose have
been going on to there adding that fuel
to the fire some of it may be out of a
genuine wish to try and help but a lot
of it is just from a sense of trying to
capitalize I would suggest on the amount
of Engagement that people know a post
that says hashtag Nicola bully will
attract but it just speaks doesn't it to
the enormous public interest in this
case you know
a person's reported missing in the UK
every 90 seconds most of those will be
names and faces that people won't know
Nicola bully has been a face now known
and recognized by so many people because
I think of
well lots of different factors but also
one of them being what she was doing on
the morning that she disappeared was a
routine so many people are familiar with
she is a mum she's dropping her kids off
to school she's taking her dog for a
walk she's multitasking she's emailing
her boss she's on a work conference call
I mean that must be the morning that
many people watching the news can can it
resonates with them and I think it's
added and contributed to the mystery and
why there's been such a huge public
interest especially when days later her
family said it's like she's just
vanished it's a mystery people I think
engaged with and wanted to feel like
they could help solve perhaps and and
you drive into the Village today and
those those posters slap the the school
is back after half term it's a reminder
I guess of that isn't it that the heart
of this was a person who was missing and
that that that family tragedy at the
heart of that yeah I mean I'm sure
you've also walked along this bridge
just behind us it's covered in ribbons
with messages and they're all so
heartfelt and you don't know do these
people know Nicola are they from the
local area I know that certainly lots of
them are from people I mean Nicola
wasn't even didn't even live in this
Village she lived three miles in a
village further down the road but her
children went to the local primary
school you know with just a couple of
meters away from the church where when I
spoke with the vicar he spoke with such
warmth and fondness about her being
there with her daughters just before
Christmas getting ready for the
festivities covered in glitter was how
he described her and everyone we have
spoken to have described Nicola as that
a warm person that they were so
desperate just to find and bring home
for her daughters and her partner poor
okay Katarina thanks for now we will
have that briefing from Lancashire
police at 5 30 of course but for now to
Mark Austin in Kiev
foreign
yes welcome back to some Michael's on
wire in Lancashire Jonathan police are
expected to give an update in the next
few minutes following the discovery of a
body in the search for the missing
mother of two Nicola bully our
correspondent Katarina vatotsi is is
here with me and of course we we talked
a little while ago about the focus on
the on the family and
um what they must be going through and
what they must have heard from the
police but we know the police won't
answer questions this evening and there
are a lot of questions for the police
yeah they have been under intense
scrutiny throughout this investigation
brought on by the huge public interests
in this case which then in some way
became a bit of a sort of a cyclical you
know they would issue statements to try
and stop speculation but in some
respects it fuels speculation and they
have been sort of trying to chase the
tail a little bit with regards to their
communication strategy because as I said
of the huge public interest in what
they've been doing we know that they
have referred themselves to the
dependent police complaints office
because of a previous welfare check or a
contact that they had with the Nicola
with Nicola Bully's family on the 10th
of January so what's 17 days before she
disappeared we know there's also an
internal review which they're conducting
which we believe is procedural it can
happen in high profile cases like this
where complex cases get a peer-led
review or an internal review to check
sort of operational tactics Etc but as
you say a police force under huge
scrutiny there have been lots of voices
um over the last week or so from former
detectives even former heads of the
Lancashire police force saying that
there does need to be a moment maybe
it's after the investigation maybe it's
now just to reflect on the strategy of
the force over the past three weeks
looking not only at the investigation
but also how they've been communicating
what they've been doing about their
lines of inquiry due to the highly
complex nature of this investigation but
as I said also the huge public interest
in it as well
massive operation has gone on and from
very early on they said that they're
working hypothesis that phrase they kept
using was that Nicola bully had gone
into the water that it didn't appear the
other hypotheses that were out there
were supported by the evidence in some
ways what they said at the beginning if
if this does turn out to be Nicola bully
has proved to be right
yeah from the very start they have
publicly said their main working
hypothesis was that she has gone into
the river they said there were three
hypotheses that they were routinely
going over rechecking and checking again
that that she's gone into the river that
there's third party involvement or that
there has been an investigation I'll let
you get them let's take you to that
press conference right now
good afternoon everyone
sadly we are now now able to confirm
that yesterday we recovered Nicola Bully
from the river wire
Nicholas family have been informed and
are of course devastated
our thoughts are with them at this time
as well as with all her loved ones and
the wider community
we recognize the huge impact that
Nicholas disappearance has had on a
family and friends
but also on the people of Saint Michael
we would like to thank all of those who
have helped during what has been a
hugely complex and high emotional
investigation
today's development is not the outcome
any of us would have wanted
but we hope that at least it can begin
to provide some answers for Nicholas
loved ones
they remain foremost in our thoughts
the case is now being handled by his
Majesty's coroner
it's a family of us that we read a
statement on their behalf I'll now hand
over to detective Chief superintendent
Pauline Stables to do that
Nicholas family have asked that we
release the following statement on their
behalf as follows
our family liaison officers have had to
confirm our worst fears today
we will never be able to comprehend what
Nikki had gone through in her last
moments and that will never leave us
we will never forget Nikki how could we
she was the center of our world
she was the one who made our lives so
special
and nothing will cast a shadow over that
our girls will get the support they need
from the people who love them the most
and it saddens us to think that one day
we will have to explain to them that the
Press
and members of the public
accuse their dad of wrongdoing
misquoted and vilified friends and
family
this is absolutely appalling
they have to be held accountable this
cannot happen to another family
we tried last night to take in what we
have been told in the day
only to have
Sky News
and ITV making contact with us directly
when we expressly asked for privacy
they again have taken it upon themselves
to run stories
about us to sell papers and increase
their own profits it is shameful they
have acted in this way
leave us alone now
do the press and other media channels
and so-called professionals not know
when to stop
these are our lives and our children's
lives
to those who genuinely helped and
supported us privately we thank you
the community support in St Michael's
friends neighbors and strangers
has been nothing short of comforting and
heartwarming
friends you know who you are thank you
our hearts truly break for others who
have missing loved ones keep that hope
alive
finally
Nikki
you are no longer a missing person you
have been found we can let you rest now
we love you
always have and always will
we will take it from here
thank you thank you everyone thank you
with that statement there from uh the
police assistant chief Constable Peter
Lawson and a statement read on behalf of
Nicola Bully's family and the police
confirming as they said there they are
able to now confirm that the body they
recovered from the river wire yesterday
was that of of Nicola bully and as you
heard there the family have been uh
informed and recognizing the huge impact
that The Disappearance has had on a
family and friends but also the people
of this this Village as well and
thanking those who've helped during
what's been a hugely complex and
emotional uh investigation not the
result they say that anybody uh wanted
but they hope it can provide some
answers or begin to provide some answers
for Nicholas family and then that that
the fact that it's now in the hands of
of the coroner to conduct the rest of
this investigation uh Katarina vatoxi is
with me and clearly as the police say
not the outcome anyone wanted from this
and and clearly from from the family a
very emotional time as well yeah
off
um the role that Nicola bully had in
their family you know describing her as
the center of our world she was the one
who made our lives so special and
nothing will cast a shadow over that and
I think that is the sense you got of the
woman
described To Us by her friends and
family here when they were so
desperately hoping that she would be
brought home safely a woman they
described as loving and caring and kind
and the news today just utterly
heartbreaking for them okay Cornell
Katarina thanks very much for we can get
some reaction to what we've just heard
from the from the police there on behalf
of the family as well from former
Lancashire police chief superintendent
Bob Eastwood
um a good evening former Chief
superintendent I mean first of all
heartbreaking for the family I wonder
what you you made of what we just heard
there from from the police on on their
behalf and behalf of the family
well I think it's really tragic you know
unfortunately you know it was predicted
by the police that this would in actual
fact be the outcome and but it doesn't
make that's any easier uh to accept by
Nicholas family and children uh they
must be absolutely devastated and you
know I don't know them but my heart
still goes out to them I think the uh
the the press release
um issued on behalf of the family was
very telling and there's a lot of people
out there that have got a lot of
learning to do on how to treat people
with more dignity and more respect
um I do not notice that some media
Outlets
um were also criticized uh and I
understand that the media got their job
to to uh to do
um so it's a very very fine fine line to
tread in order to do that but I think
the pressure that the family has been
brought under by some vile comments that
have been made against the husband
pointing the finger with no evidence
whatsoever
against the husband was appalling you
know some of these Specialists that I
referred to in previous interviews one
of whom came back thinking that he could
find Nicholas body in the undergrowth
with absolutely no evidence whatsoever
you know hashtagging Nicholas name uh
going about this in the most
unprofessional of ways and all the time
that this was having a devastating
impact on Nicola and her family that
basically wanted some peaceful end to
all this and hope that she was going to
be found alive and well and very sadly
it hasn't but all those people who need
to to examine and scrutinize their own
consciences in order to
have an appreciation of how negatively
they've impacted on the way that this
family had felt during this time and
notwithstanding I'd also like to say the
same members
of Lancashire please language can
stability some of the way that their
officers have been treated their
investigation has been trashed on many
occasions it's been absolutely appalling
and all the time they've been doing
their best for the family and all they
can do uh to find to find Nicola and I
just think there's a lot of elements of
this that they're just so sad
they are really really sad and a lot of
people have made it unfortunately 10
times worse for the family and the
police doing their best
there's been a lot of discussion about
this investigation and obviously that
that intense scrutiny as you you
mentioned do you think when obviously
when the focus will be on the family and
the the awful news that they're
confronting uh tonight do you think
there are questions about how this
police investigation was handled whether
lessons need to be learned for for the
searches for the for the many people who
go missing
yeah I do obviously uh relationships
between the police and the media has
been raised quite a bit today that that
clearly needs reviewing for the better
of everybody but it's also the part
that's played by people that have
literally pushed themselves in between
the family and the police they've push
themselves into the investigation
they've had no right to do that they've
been they've been themselves running
interviews on the uh the banks of the
river they'd been
you know dominating social media some of
which have had hundreds of thousands of
hits you know and it is just a terrible
thing to have to manage when what you're
trying to do is do your best to support
the family and find and find Nicola you
know and I think a lot of people
um would you know appreciate the
pressure the police have been under and
so it's hardly surprising uh some
mistakes will no doubt have been made
the mistakes are made in all walks of
life you know you can always do better
and I'm sure the police uh will reflect
on that and I think the Press of that
part to playing that and the Press can
help the place because this will this
will be used nationally I'm sure the
Press can help the place uh acknowledge
some of the things that could have done
better so there's better for everybody
else Nicholas family finished off in
relation to how they want other families
to be uh to be treated
and I'll just also mention you know the
role that tick tockers have played in
this you know the police have had a
significant Balancing Act they've also
had responsibility for placing the rest
of Lancashire don't forget and this this
Balancing Act has been made worse
because of these tick tockers some of
whom have turned up in the woods with a
spade
digging for no reason whatsoever what
sort of impression were they trying to
leave people with you know and it's
ridiculous there were members of the
local community in Saint Michael's that
were harassed the police had to take out
um a dispersal notice you know these
things are not taken out as a matter of
course but they had to be taken out
because people were visiting this area
of Lancashire a small quiet Village and
they were harassing the residents and
the police needed to protect the
residents
you know there's a lot of things that
have gone into this that have probably
made this and it was it this was
described by another reporter as the
absolute perfect storm and I I agree
with that and there's a lot of things
that have gone in there to make this a
very challenging and at times very
unsaving experience for all concerned
you um you described this I think
earlier today as a watershed in in terms
of policing I think what what do you
think is will have changed in in
policing and how police deal with with
investigations like this going forward
well they're a leader review a full
review in relation to various aspects
you know Lancashire police uh at a very
very honest
um decent police force in my view uh and
you know they need to be given the
opportunity to reflect on uh what they
did well and what they could have done
better and uh I'm sure they'll go
through that process all police forces
and all forward-thinking organizations
do this and like she can stability needs
to do that as soon as possible while
still supporting Nicholas family they
will still continue sporting Nichols
family I'm sure of that and because
that's what they've done in the past uh
and you know the Press can play their
part in that what what learning the the
Press have by way of feedback for the
police you know what the Press would do
differently you'll notice Nicholas
family in a very in a speech that was
delivered with a great heartfelt and
Emotion by the police officers just
delivered that speech you know there is
some learning in there for the Press you
know and the Press equally could do with
doing things differently I'm sure and
then how do how do the place and the
press manage the intrusion into their
business by by people who project
themselves as experts they run their own
uh interviews
um there's also the tick tockers and so
on you know this isn't just a police
press issue there's a lot of things to
consider in all this and I think you
know the pressured support languages
should place it in the way that they
deal with this for the benefits of the
rest of the country's place for us
because no doubt these sorts of
pressures won't go away for the future
I'm former Chief superintendent from
Lancashire police Bob Eastwood thanks
very much for joining us um on Sky News
responding to that that confirmation
from Lancashire police that to the body
recovered yesterday was that of of
Nicola bully uh joining us now is former
detective constable in Greater
Manchester police uh Maggie Oliver um
thanks very much for for joining us
again I wonder what your reaction is to
what we heard from Lancashire police and
on behalf of the family there
I think it's a tragic case
um my heart goes out to the family but I
do feel I I used to be as well as a
detective a family as an officer so I'm
very well used to families having to
deal with the shock of losing a loved
one but I do feel that
um at least now they do have an element
of closure they know
um that their daughter or wife
um is not um somewhere and and never
they will never have any answers they
know that she's not coming back home
which is heartbreaking and you know I
did listen to the news conference
um
and I think
um a great deal of my thoughts uh have
focused on the disclosures of the police
um into what I see as highly personal
information
um and it took me back to to my
experience and and what my experience is
today that there was a feeling of
um victim blaming to me by saying that
um Nicolo the implication was that she
was an alcoholic that she was a a woman
who had problems and and I saw that as
excuses for not finding her I'm also
shocked Jonathan that um it's members of
the public that found her body less than
a mile away from where they thought
she'd gone into the river and the
question has to be asked
um with all these
um underwater search teams how could it
be that she had not been found earlier
um and it was really a challenge
exciting that discovered her body so I
think that there are a lot of questions
there to be answered I think a lot of my
concerns are around the communication
that there has been a breakdown in
communication from the police to the
public and when that communication
finally did come
um it raised
um a feeling of
concern with me that um I saw it as a
really
um kind of justification for why this
young woman had perhaps fallen in the
river before anybody could actually
confirm that she had
do you not feel with the release of that
personal information for example which
was the subject of huge criticism do you
not feel that the police were it was
part of a strategy that they'd taken a
decision that that would help this
search this would help their
investigation
I personally don't I don't see
single reason why that would help an
investigation not one little bit and you
know it with my background working in
child abuse and um child sexual
exploitation I repeatedly see
um police officers and police forces
trying to
um blame the children for their own
abuse by you know victim blaming you
know they were making how many times
have we heard they were making a
lifestyle choice or they came from a
dysfunctional family or they were
roaming the streets at night when they
shouldn't have been this really
triggered me in that same way
um that it really was unnecessary I
would say it was unlawful because that
was highly confidential information and
I don't think it added anything to the
the picture there were clearly working
on a hypothesis they say
um the question I asked myself as a
former police officer
um who regularly dealt with missing from
homes when I first joined greater
Manchester police is did that thinking
at the beginning
um lead to this being treated in a less
than serious way
um that you know the initial visiting of
the scene it wasn't it wasn't uh
preserved there was no I think the
Assumption was made early doors
um that this young woman had alcohol
problems she's fallen in and maybe that
um limited the extent of the
investigation for perhaps three or four
days and at which point they then
brought in a senior investigating
officer but it does beg the question
um it may not have altered the outcome
in the end bearing in mind what we now
know but until today we didn't actually
know that this young woman had fallen in
the river you know there were other
hypotheses that she'd been addicted that
she could have left on her own and I
just feel that the job of a police
officer is to follow the lines of
inquiry not to speculate
um and entering that you know truly
personal information into the arena I
feel
you know is detrimental and and you know
undermines the the
the
you know the the reputation of this
young woman and I think it was
completely and entirely unnecessary
that's my personal feeling
just briefly what are the lessons that
need to be learned this early on do you
think
I think you know we can't we live in a
world where the media is
um Central to any case that grabs the
headlines
um I don't know why this case grabbed
the headlines for instance I'm aware of
an almost identical case ongoing in in
Booth town in Manchester where a young
man has gone missing possibly fallen in
the canal and yet you don't see coverage
of that anywhere
um I don't know why this case caught the
headlines
um but I do think communication is key
uh I do think that police forces have a
long way to go in learning how to
communicate with the media with the
public
um and I think maybe with the with the
best intentions further on down the road
um they have begun to share information
I think that could have been done
earlier
um and you know it does beg the question
as to why she was not found earlier I'm
sure there will be an inquiry looking up
we missed opportunities
it looks as though possibly it wouldn't
have changed the outcome but really
nobody knows that and as a former police
officer you I know that your job is to
follow lines of inquiry and not jump to
conclusions from day one which it looks
to me
um is what was done
um unfortunately
you mentioned you worked as a family
liaison or you saw the work of family
liaison officers just I guess finally
the thoughts with with the family uh
tonight you've heard the the worst
possible news
heartbreaking
um heartbreaking but at least you know
they do have an answer you know as a mum
myself and you know
um I can think of nothing worse than
having
um a child go missing and you never have
any idea what actually happened to that
child
um obviously it's slim Comfort because
Nicola is not going home again but um at
least now they can begin to
um to plan and to grieve her um knowing
that she isn't hasn't been abducted
isn't being abused in some horrendous
way it's heartbreaking and it's sad but
um I think not having answers is far
worse in many respects than at least
having
um some kind of closure to the loss of
of this young woman which is really sad
Debbie Oliver formerly of Greater
Manchester police thank you very much
for your time this evening on a
difficult night um for the family just a
reminder the police confirming that body
that was discovered in the river here
yesterday was that of Nicola bully and
then a statement read by the police on
behalf of uh Nicola Bully's family here
is that statement from police
good afternoon everyone
sadly we are now now able to confirm
that yesterday we recovered Nicola Bully
from the river wire
Nicholas family have been informed and
are of course devastated
our thoughts are with them at this time
as well as with all her loved ones and
the wider community
we recognize the huge impact that
Nicholas disappearance has had on a
family and friends
but also on the people of Saint Michael
we would like to thank all of those who
have helped during what has been a
hugely complex and high emotional
investigation
today's development is not the outcome
any of us would have wanted
but we hope that at least it can begin
to provide some answers for Nicholas
loved ones
they remain foremost in our thoughts
the case is now being handled by his
Majesty's coroner
well joining us now is Skies police
analyst Graham wetton and Graham good
evening to you an awful night for the
for the family in this community of
course what are your Reflections on what
the police had to say what the family
had to say in that that briefing a
little while ago
well I think the family statement was
really telling I think it actually sums
up what many of us have been saying over
the last few weeks is that the family
going through such a wretched time but
the speculation uh the false information
the false accusations has clearly
impacted on them and they are aware of
them all and I think that's why you've
seen the investigation develop as it has
over the last few weeks any information
come back from Lancashire police they'll
be reviewing to this but once it's all
finished with the fan we've got one
answer now to where nickler is but they
still don't know actually how it all
happened to her so the investigation
will still be ongoing to actually try
and establish what actually happened on
the day but there will be a review
process it needs to be reviewed and
looked at
every police investigation's reviewed
after us or whatever you've done so
they'll be looking at that and it isn't
about marketing around homework police
reviews are quite intensive and are
quite critical on occasions they will
look at what they could have done but
ultimately the decisions rest with the
senior investigations officer you've
heard a couple of police commentators
already and there's already slightly
different points of view and you'll get
that in any Walker life but specifically
in policing but it comes down to one
person having said unjustified and it'll
be all written down in a decision of
exactly why I've decided to take the
actions they did at the time they did
and the reasons behind it there'll be a
rationale for all the decisions made and
that's been what will be looked at and
reviewed and then decided whether that
was the best cultivation at the time
what do they put in an alternative one
and what are the actions that need
answers most of all in your mind
I think you just heard it there's
there's huge huge controversy of
criticism about the the information that
was released last week and I think they
actually got into a position where from
the very beginning they've had this this
main Theory this main um scenario I
thought would happen to Nicola but they
were still keep an open mind about the
possibility of maybe an abduction or she
went away herself so they're still
investigating other revenues but they
didn't quite they didn't quite close
that it seems for people they seem to be
in a Public's perception and maybe
sections of the media they were only
focused on the river and that was that
was clearly that's where the Intensive
search was taking place so I think there
was almost like a misapprehension from
from some sections of of the public and
the media that the police have ignored
every other possibility which which for
me wasn't the case but again that
decision-making process and the way they
released that information there needs to
be like a look at almost like the media
policy the media strategy which there
will have been one but it's whether it
was it was done correctly and in the
right times I think they've done a
really good job uh overall when you take
everything into account there will have
been slight mistakes made they wouldn't
there may be decisions made that when
they reflect on them think they could
have done it better but you get that in
every investigation
do you think we've seen in this
investigation or how much have we seen
in this investigation the the external
influences of social media these Tick
Tock detectives we hear about how much
more difficult the police's job is
becoming conducting an investigation
like this when they obviously want uh
publicity and attention to help with
that investigation
yeah definitely there's a fine line
between appealing for information at the
right time and asking for the right kind
of information
um I've I've never seen such an
unprecedented like like interest in the
case I think one of your previous
guesses mentioned it there's there's
similar missing persons across the
country people go missing every day but
this one seems to attract the attention
of people for whatever reason then there
was speculation on various social media
and social forums I've not known such a
such a a glare of publicity
um and that attracted the media and they
then started speculating and it was
almost a vacuum creative information
that people would talk about and then
people started almost trying to create
themselves what had actually taken place
so I think that needs looking at again
the the volume of interest in this case
has been use the word unprecedented but
it has been I've never known anything
like this and the level of criticism
again has been unprecedented so I think
Lancashire almost felt like they had to
come out and say some things that
sometimes that maybe maybe they wouldn't
have done if there hadn't been so much
either interest or criticism at certain
stages
the release of personal information that
attracted so much criticism was was that
a mistake in your view
almost in a corner with a hatch released
something because they've been
criticized so heavily and in so many
quarters about why are they taking such
a course of action she was clearly a
high risker from the start based on the
information they had at the time but
they didn't make that information public
they then start to be criticized about
the actions they had taken so they
almost had to come out to justify why
their decisions had been made at certain
times so there was clearly a reason what
I had to release and I think they used a
word or the term vulnerabilities at
first then it seems they were then being
either it was being speculated on what
those vulnerabilities are so they had to
then release a further statement to
clarify what they were so my knowledge
this was all with with the consent and
the knowledge of the family so for me
it's almost like you're working for the
family's wishes at the Mona Spate to try
and actually find some solution for them
you almost have to exclude yourself to a
certain degree from the criticism and
and the the suggestions the ideas from
everywhere else so for me I think it was
probably but again I haven't got the
decision logs it will come down to a
review of those decision logs and
actually whoever made the decision to
actually release that information at
that time why they did it in a
justification for it
Graham wetton thanks very much for your
reaction instant reaction to what we've
heard from Lancashire police tonight and
that confirmation of the to the body
found yesterday was that of of Nicola
bully um Catherine of plotsy is still
with me a lot of discussion about the
police of course but at the heart of
this tonight is a family that um now
knows the the truth of what happened
particular in the statement that was
read out on their behalf by Lancashire
police today it's worth repeating those
words so heartbreaking that we will
never forget Nikki how could we she was
the center of our world and from being
here over the past three weeks and
speaking with her friends and family
so many people have got a sense of the
woman that Nicola bully was a loving
mother
such a huge part of this community a
church Community the school Community we
were speaking with friends who said
we've known her since our babies were
little and we went to mothers and
toddlers groups and amidst all the
commentary and criticism and the
inevitable discussion that there will be
now about the investigation about the
things surrounding the investigations I
think that statement really just summing
up that the family want this to be about
the missing woman the mother the
daughter the sister that they were so
desperately hoping would come home the
center of their world as they describe
and unfortunately that heartbreaking
news that the body recovered was that of
the person they were so desperately
hoping would be brought home to them to
their two daughters Harriet and severe
heartbreaking
well if you're just joining us a
reminder of the breaking news from here
in Lancashire and in the last half hour
police have confirmed that a body found
in the river wire close to where I'm
standing is that of Nicola bully
her body was discovered yesterday close
to the place where she was last seen
walking her dog after she dropped her
two daughters off at school that was
just over three weeks ago on the 27th of
January police gave this update a short
time ago
good afternoon everyone
sadly we are now now able to confirm
that yesterday we recovered Nicola Bully
from the river wire
Nicholas family have been informed and
are of course devastated
our thoughts are with them at this time
as well as with all her loved ones and
the wider community
we recognize the huge impact that
Nicholas disappearance has had on a
family and friends
but also on the people of St Michael's
we would like to thank all of those who
have helped during what has been a
hugely complex and high emotional
investigation
today's development is not the outcome
any of us would have wanted
but we hope that at least it can begin
to provide some answers for Nicholas
loved ones
they remain foremost in our thoughts
the case is now being handled by his
Majesty's coroner
the felony of us that we read a
statement on their behalf I'll now hand
over to detective Chief superintendent
Pauline Stables to do that
Nicholas family have asked that we
release the following statement on their
behalf as follows
our family liaison officers have had to
confirm our worst fears today
we will never be able to comprehend what
Nikki had gone through in her last
moment and that will never leave us
we will never forget Nikki how could we
she was the center of our world
she was the one who made our lives so
special
and nothing will cast a shadow over that
all girls will get the support they need
from the people who love them the most
and it saddens us to think that one day
we will have to explain to them that the
Press
and members of the public
accuse their dad of wrongdoing
misquoted and vilified friends and
family
this is absolutely appalling
they have to be held accountable this
cannot happen to another family
we tried last night to take in what we
have been told in the day
only to have
Sky News
and ITV making contact with us directly
when we expressly asked for privacy
they again have taken it upon themselves
to run stories
about us to sell papers and increase
their own profits
it is shameful
they have acted in this way
leave us alone now
do the press and other media channels
and so-called professionals not know
when to stop
these are our lives and our children's
lives
to those who genuinely helped and
supported us privately we thank you
the community support in St Michael's
friends neighbors and strangers
has been nothing short of comforting and
heartwarming
friends you know who you are thank you
our hearts truly break for others who
have missing loved ones keep that hope
alive
finally
Nikki
you are no longer a missing person you
have been found
we can let you rest now
we love you
always have and always will
we will take it from here
thank you thank you everyone thank you
well that statement read by police
officer on behalf of Nicola Bully's
family of course and before that
confirmation from the police of what
they've discovered following that to the
discovery of that body in the river
yesterday our correspondent Katarina
vitotsi is here with me um and Katarina
striking that thanks from the family for
the for the community because this
devastating for the family but
devastating for the friends and for
everyone who's tried so hard over the
last few months yeah I think we've been
struck how the community not just from
this Village but the village three miles
away where Nicola bully lived came
together to try and contribute in
whatever way they could
um to try and find her ultimately
everyone was just so desperate for her
to be able to be brought home and
brought home safely and we saw in the
immediate days after her Disappearance
in the local Tennis Club they were
organizing a community-led search to go
along inside that of the police we saw
people wandering around with maps that
have been printed out by by neighbors by
friends of Nicola trying to retrace her
route trying to do anything they could
to generate publicity
to keep her name in the headlines to
make her feel known by people so that
they could try and
if they could try to listen a little bit
of information that that could have
brought her home safely and I think
we've been hugely struck by that and by
how Frank and open people have been to
let us know the sort of woman that
Nicola bully was
kind caring a wonderful mother partner
daughter sister neighbor
and the most heartbreaking of news you
could you could feel it it felt raw or
even in a statement read by a police
officer you could feel how raw and
heartbreaking what else could it be the
most horrendous of news to receive and
like you say a community a small
community I remember being so struck
even in the first conversation I had
with a friend of Nicholas where she said
you know we're the sort of people we
leave we lead a quiet life here we walk
our dogs we take our children to school
and we're not ashamed of leading a quiet
life this is a small village that has
become the center of this story that has
generated enormous public interest
and that sense now that it is a moment
for the family for this community to
pause reflect and grieve
a woman
and this heartbreaking news and so much
focus on the police investigation forget
about it but it was a massive it has
been a massive unprecedented police
operation yeah absolutely last week the
Lancashire police broke it down into
numbers 300 homes searched and
outbuilding search and Caravan searched
thousands of lines of inquiry followed
up on dash cam footage CCTV footage
analyzed
and because of the huge public interest
in this there were there was so much
information for Lancashire police to
have to filter and then by their own
admission on Wednesday in a press
conference were giving perhaps more
information not even perhaps they said
they were giving more information than
they normally would on an act in
investigation that was open and active
but it reflected the enormous scale of
the operation and the enormous scale of
the public interest and we know that
there are now that there was an internal
inquiry that Lancashire police said it
was doing something which is routine in
a case that has become so high profile
and so complex and it's an internal
review to support that own investigation
we know there's also a separate referral
by the police to the police Watchdog
because of that previous contact that
they had with Nicola Bully's family on
the 10th of January okay Katarina now
thanks very much well focusing on the
police now we can speak to former deputy
assistant commissioner for the
Metropolitan Police Stephen Roberts
um thanks very much for joining us this
evening I can only imagine you must know
from your work in the police there can't
be many more awful things for for a
police force to have to do than break
that news that they have tonight what
are your thoughts on on what you've
heard in the last hour
it's sad it's tragic we
we can only offer our sympathies to the
family uh but as some of your other
commentators have said at least now they
have a degree of certainty uh at least
now uh Nicola can be laid to rest
they can start to try and find some
peace and the police operation will
continue actually to make sure that
every bit of evidence that the coroner
may need will be available to him or her
um and quite correctly and absolutely
routinely there will be a review of
everything that's been done because in
this operation as in all operations
there are lessons to be learned perhaps
the the strongest lesson here will will
flow out of the
perceived failure to manage the media
and the difficulties that senior
investigating officers have managing
both the official media TV radio the
printed press as opposed to social media
um which can and in this case did
complicate matters and generate problems
that the investigators really could have
done without
you say perceived failures do you think
they they were failures what do you
think needs to be addressed from what
you've seen from the outside
I think what needs to be addressed and
what needs to be reviewed uh are the
reasons why the disclosures of sensitive
information were made uh the
justification for that and that needs to
be set alongside uh The Unofficial media
social media traffic that was going on
at the time we've had some hints of that
even from the family statement uh about
appalling rumors being circulated uh on
the internet that being senior
investigating officer felt that she had
to manage and couldn't limit uh by
disclosing information that would not
normally be released
how how different how how different how
much more difficult is it for police
force dealing with that that external
Factor now that didn't exist a few years
ago of of social media of of it being
just beyond the traditional media and
it's seemingly everyone in the world
able to to insert themselves into an
investigation
it does make life much more difficult
the the public have come to believe that
there's some sort of obligation on
police services to disclose absolutely
everything about a major investigation
well that's not always possible
sometimes it is absolutely essential
both of the purposes of the
investigation itself and for the privacy
of victims and the privacy of families
to hold sensitive information back even
to the extent of the police appearing to
be stubborn to be being awkward uh to be
being secretive but sometimes the senior
investigating officer has to just say
well okay this is not going to be a
popular decision but it's what I need to
do in order to further the investigation
what the sio is responsible for is a
successful investigation and we
shouldn't forget however tragic the
conclusion this was ultimately
successful Nicholas body has been found
and has been identified
do you think things will change as a
result of this however long it takes to
to review what has happened in this case
I think this case could quite easily
become a case study for future senior
investigating officers about the
management of official media as opposed
to social media
um consideration I think should be given
even at home office level uh to the ways
in which the official media might be
able to help to manage social media
this case has attracted huge huge
attention not just from Skype from all
the TV and radio stations and from the
printed media
to the exclusion of quite a few other
similar uh
missing persons cases now there's an
issue there that's responsible editors
ought to be considering about whether
they in their wish to support the public
in their wish to inform the public and
let's not forget to sell newspapers and
to sell TV programs the amount of
coverage that they give to cases the
amount of grandstanding that they
facilitate in others both politicians
and in the public
what is what would be the one lesson
from what you've seen from outside what
would be the one lesson you hope is is
taken away from what we've seen over the
last 24 days
I think probably the strongest lesson is
to be a little more open about for
example uh the extent of the search of
the river obviously as we now know it
was entirely Justified that the prime
hypothesis was in fact correct but I've
heard so much criticism that this search
of the river was somehow incompetent or
questionable
I'm no specialist in underwater
searching but I do know that it is
phenomenally difficult it's prone to
error and well quite apart from anything
else it's quite dangerous for the people
doing the search but it certainly isn't
a guarantee that you are going to find a
body in a river most of all a tidal
River that's deep that has heavily
wooded and reeded sides for bodies that
may have been in there for a number of
days or weeks now those difficulties
could have been put in front of the
public quite helpfully I think and they
would have perhaps modified people's
expectations of what could be done and
what might be done
former deputy assistant commissioner of
the Met Stephen Roberts thanks very much
for your thoughts almost a difficult
night of course for the the police
involved in this search but ultimately
for Nicola Bully's family confirming
that body found in the river yesterday
was hers and the tribute from her family
here in Lancashire tonight that's it for
now from here I take it to Mark Austin
in Kiev